so many movies in the pipeline lots of
things coming out but I noticed still no
sign of the Fresh Prince of bel-air
reboot that everyone wants you did Drive
you posted this was a reunion so every
year Karen has a she I think it's I
think I don't think it's I think it's
just national but she has no it's not it
is international where she has a
charitable event and she hosts a lunch
with the cast of The Fresh Prince so we
do that every year and it'll be you know
ten or twelve people from around the
world that have won this Wow so that's a
that's in Los Angeles and the people
flew in and we have the lunch with the
fans who gave the most to charity and
you mentioned you mentioned you would
play Uncle Phil a weird thing happened
you I think you were in Africa and you
jump a bungee jump yes some people film
this and then you from the rest oh here
you are
yeah bungee - so there you go and then
you are filming yourself on like a
gopher or something people notice that
if you freeze frame it at a certain
point yes you look remarkably like
like who's going through it frame by